foreign
UK and welcome to this the final debate
of how the light gets in 2020 Up For
Debate today sexuality power and porn
and critic support have long argued that
it's organized by men for men with women
as the exploited puppets of the show but
now supporters argue A rafter women
directors are making porn for women and
with more than a third of women
accessing porn every week making up 30
of all those who view pornography
perhaps the new audience is here should
we see this as an extension of an
already dangerous industry that turns
human beings into products and users
into addicts or is it time to celebrate
the liberation of female desire and
escape from a Century's old vision of
female sexuality this is a pertinent
debate to be having in this moment when
numbers suggests that more people than
ever are accessing porn in lockdown even
if our varying Arrangements domestically
and shall we say instincts mean that
accessing that acts as ranges between us
all and we have four fantastic speakers
is with us to debate the issues today
can I introduce first up Victoria Brooks
a writer an academic whose research
interests includes sex and its
relationships to Identity femininity
philosophy and law she is the author of
[ __ ] law the search for her sexual
ethics one of the best main books we
have in Blackwell's during this Festival
um we have also here Sally Phillips an
actor and comedian best known for her
starring roles in the award-winning
sketch comedy series smack Pony as well
as Miranda and the Bridget Jones trilogy
former labor party parliamentary
candidate Peter tatchell a lifelong
human rights activist and a key figure
in Outrage an LGBT plus Rights group
where he has been involved in a wide
array of process and activism and
finally welcome to Kate Dublin who is a
sex robot theorist and computer
scientist senior lecturer at King's
College London and the author of turned
on science sex and robots is the rise of
female generated porn a win for feminism
can I start possibly with you Victoria
on this one yes thank you very much
um so I would say yes uh female lead
porn is a win for feminism and this is
because it means that porn by women for
women means that real women's desire is
reflected and at last represented on
screen which has to be a win for
feminism
um women will now have an increasing
Choice
um about watching porn without having to
choose either between not watching it at
all or to watch porn catering to
Conventional heterosexual male desire
which may either be harmful to them or
at least is not catering to their ways
of Desiring so more women-led porn means
in my opinion sexier porn
um women have an opportunity to watch
their desires being played out on screen
which is a chance to explore and
experiment with sexuality uh either Solo
or with partners and this is an
opportunity that was not there before
um or maybe it was but not in such a
free way
um given pawns very limited
um heterosexual scripts
um which means it places women's desire
at the center of pornography
um hopefully the representation of uh
queer makers of porn
um or queer women pornographers is on is
on the rise as well alongside women-led
porn meaning that queer and diverse
bodies and bodies of color are going to
be increasingly represented in
pornography and hopefully the the vast
array of sexualities and sexual desires
that women have too
um although I've got to say that this
needs to continue to develop and to grow
for this to be a true win for feminism
that sounds like quite a lot of good
news already
um to celebrate so I sort of turned to
Sally and say is this course for
celebration particularly is this cause
for feminist celebration
um well I mean I you know it's all very
compelling and this is the how the light
gets in festivals so of course the
answer is a rhetorical question here is
for feminism but I just as you know my
job on the panel is to be the Mary White
House of the group I would just urge
caution because I would say that
um I'm just going to give you some
gender gaps and facts okay about women
represented in the media like why uh why
is it why is it growing so much faster
for pornography than in other areas okay
I would say that
um
I would say that yes uh women's desire
being freely represented is good and
that would be an outworking of women
having more equality however
um I when it's not represented in other
areas I wonder why it is that we're
being allowed to grow here and not in
other areas of the media so if I just
give you some stats
um only 26 of subjects and sources and
internet and Tweets in the news of women
only 13 of news stories from conflict
areas involve women 16 of political
reporters are women four percent of
political analysts on previous U.S
elections or women of color only 14 of
A1 lead photos are bi women and um that
was a stat from demand 71 of all front
page stories are written by men eight
percent of USA print Newsroom star for
women of color seventy percent of Acts
of intimidation threats or abuse happen
at work one in every two journalists who
suffered sexual harassment psychological
abuse and online trolling only 23 of
spokespeople use the women only 14 of
Indian TV news panels women only 19 of
experts use the women 17 uh gender pay
Gap in the EU in the media only 29 of
middle management positions in the media
are held by women
six of the hundred largest global media
Corps have women CEOs 80 of boards are
men at the top 100 media corporations
so perhaps there are more urgent fights
well not just
say it's interesting
um
yeah I just say it's interesting that
we've we're being allowed to do this I
wonder if there's a kind of containment
and uh because it's I think I think I
wonder if those are keeping us down by
allowing this but not other areas I I
think that it's I think that it's false
really I think it's I think it's a
mirage of Freedom
um okay I might turn to Peter at that
point and then Sally thank you so much
for that and for those statistics
porn and feminism uh can we talk even in
context of winds here is there a more
urgent fight
but my starting point is that there's
nothing wrong with the naked human body
and our genitals there's also nothing
wrong with sex it's natural and healthy
and if you accept those premises then
surely there could be nothing wrong with
visual depictions nudity and sex
providing of course it involves adults
and is genuinely consensual
however of course we do have to
acknowledge that much of the porn
industry is degrading and humiliating to
women and that is so so wrong I oppose
that just as I oppose the traffic and
coercion of some women in the porn
industry we've got to end that we've got
to give those women a way out
but these abuses and they are real
doesn't mean that all porn is ipso facto
automatically and always abusive
as we've heard feminist porn by and for
women is an attempt to show that porn
doesn't have to be abusive and
misogynistic
I think it's also worth pointing out
that uh sadly not everyone has a partner
and Singletons also have a right to
sexual fulfillment
and one of the great things about porn
when it's genuinely consensual between
adults uh and it's not humiliating or
degrading is that can give everyone
equal access to sexual happiness
regardless of their age their looks
their ability or disability their
location
so it can be in some circumstances a
great leveler and I think of you know
people perhaps you live in isolated
rural communities you don't have
opportunities for sexual Outlets or
relationships for them porn can the only
way that they have sexual fulfillment
and maybe at times like this in lockdown
also these issues kind of rise to the
surface and we'll definitely come back
to that so is this about the fact that
it's female generated porn that's the
good thing Kate uh what's your sort of
basic position on this
uh well in fact feminism is a very broad
church and there's a lot of
international Wars in it so there are
going to be quite a few people who think
there's no such thing it's not possible
to have feminist porn because they think
that just the whole concept is just
completely exploitative I I disagree
because I'm very Pro sex in my feminism
uh and I think as long as we can avoid
exploitation and that's the really hard
part as long as we can avoid
exploitation then um it can only be a
good thing because surely bringing
pleasure into people's lives is a very
very positive thing and we know that it
it's really good for our mental health
we know it's really good for our
physical health
um and I think that it's something to
that we should embrace and that we
should really
um we should Champion but I also agree
with Sally that this is why are we not
seeing more in the mainstream as well
maybe part of me is thinking well you
know if we can Corner the pornography
Market maybe we can get a slice of that
money maybe that's a good thing but I
agree as well this is the representation
of women in mainstream media is sorely
missing so you know how can we make
inroads there as well to continue
watching this video click the link in
the top left or in the description below
or visit iai.tv for more debates and
talks from the world's leading thinkers
on today's biggest ideas